tra gli agenti ragazzi e benvenuti sia
questo nuovo video io sono quel genio ci
siamo con il mister zauli dei ragazzi
allora oggi faremo la sfida un po
particolare e si tratta di il bel po
bird bird erano dei veri hong kong su
rocket league ovviamente abbiamo i
nostri bicchieri che sono 16 ciascuno
non possiamo fare invasione di campo
bisogna buttare la palla nei bicchieri
dell'avversario uno può parare anche
volendo la particolarità è che giochiamo
veramente aver poi nel senso che ho
preparato appunto i bicchieri questi 61
va da laico il primo di madama parlo io
proprio di non avere esco io che gioco
in casa allora le scopre tra attenzione
va dai lo trasmetta vi mai questo non
pensavo se fuori dal web
era la mia parte di campo di giove frey
non si vedono ma quello che mi aspettavo
che entro stato proprio lui giulio no
ragazzi gli unici che sanno aver mai
fatto subito così sono che click e
parzialmente pazzesco raramente vai
notturno carote l'ispra una bomba ma
bomba di una bomba lo sa bene
non è vero sono scarso madonna quanto
disparata che sta arrivando in mezzo al
campo ma che dovevano e non sono né
chiuso né vero come si fa a essere così
in nome arrivino io sono
astemio io un paio di volte
esatto che non bevo ma quando bevo a mi
dà fastidio fidel normalmente va bene ma
penso che farò a fare questa cosa è
orribile volevo fare 3 1 pensavo dal
aspettassi corto infante ritiro dopo
segnato dai che non era brutta idea
protezione s scoperto da me no mi hai
giocato sono veramente un rondoni
facendo le cappellate dopo l'altro che
va bene ciao caro milione vero dai ma
hanno pagato la palla ma com'è possibile
dai 40 tu sei stato carino non è l'unico
bicchiere che la pieno dai ragazzi
veramente ma che anzi quando giocato gli
europei 10 maggio giocato gli europei ma
va niente eh ma arriva abbastanza pesa
senato anche alla gente
oddio io sono stupido niente non sono
capace tanto che non gioco rocket lì che
si vede non è vero e giù giù giù giù
merita meritatissimo sono veramente
scarso alla tua canora ma comunque non
posso andare aiuto modo vecchio finirci
anche se con somma di andare vicino non
è mai andato bene ma quello era già con
il vino allora è vero lei è quella deve
entrare lo stesso però le tensioni con
lo staff hanno fatto bene a far propria
perché
[Musica]
ma io come cazzo gioca con questa norma
come si fa a giocare lo spettacolo come
faccio a essere così scarso ma anche se
gli impegni è orribile
prego entra in questo piccolo non vale
non barbato è entrato perché non vai che
ho fatto in maniera fattiva ok ok 9
passo veloce lo zero e vabbè ma che
cacchio marcia faccio mai appare
impossibile
ho fatto solo il primo però mai più no
cosa e dai sciolto lo presta una volta
questo vale ragazzi la pa è come la
palla corta nel tennessee infami stima
l'altro è un bicchiere anche l'entrata
con dietro la vista questo è un
bicchierone zona guarda il tiro del mus
una guarda bellissimo trovato però
pulire però le fan che trovi in porta e
centrato cosa è successo dopo
me lo sono perso per tornare indietro no
non mi fate schifo come descritti da
parte di non possa perché me la fa
vedere in povero dai ha sì ho visto ha
fatto il giro incredibile bella bella
bella lernia che sta bene ed è un ben 33
quanto siamo tra tre perché trattano
quasi centra due ma tenete avuto già
altre volte perché ho dovuto fare questo
che non raccontano di 33 a questo motivo
non ho avuto una madonna che cosa ho
visto e strumentale entrava rientravo
trova andata andava vita attiva
regalarti un pallone
la fortissima domanda è ma infatti gli
obiettivo era quello di farlo entrare
anche da dietro perché si può fare
questo è difficilissimo è successo ma mi
trasmetta li dai tu sai bene che lo
sapete il bello è che lo sapevo che odio
che odio e tutela olio donna e vabbè
allora prendi allora che fai con aaron
mai vinceva gli europei non ho capito se
mi stai dicendo non mi ricordo con
ventola che tiro pazzesco non ci sono
sconvolto pazzesco non solo anche se era
pieno il bicchiere o meno no quello no
al centro milioni serve insomma ci sono
le tecniche che non conosciamo che a
furia di giocare aver fondi si
potrebbero sbloccare non le sappiamo
sono pazzo io sono una donna ragazzi ma
come faccio se fiskars ok
me ne vado subito dai ragazzi bella
bella bella mamma mia un tiro era un
chilometro dai e rimbalza ben o potuta
fare così anche se la lungo perché mi
sto capendo solo 14 minuti di partita
con 15 tensione è madonna l'ho dovuta
togliere però forse vi sono tanto io sì
ne abbiamo scelti non sono vespa quali
stato dichiarato via maestra più dal
centro ok ok buono buono ha rischiato
contro la rischia vecchio perché non si
parla di lara me ne vado subito non è
vero ma dai non ci passa quanto vedete
un po tu ancora due lo stesso addio
qualche addio dai la macron e giusta era
era kick off
giusta la nostra che da solo fi wire
atac che passano non è l'egitto non è
giusto che era lei che non è giusto che
non trovo giusto per dio e per quel 55
ragazzi anche se il punto decisivo
contro perché si è pagato a me manca
solo quello centrale questo che manca il
mio centrale è esattamente lo stesso ma
se pagato anche a metà riguardano circa
il 5 manca solo pensato progettato la
faccia facciamo così non ce l'abbiamo
tutti coperti nonstante il bug
a questo punto basta centrarne uno che
un po di paura però possono essere reso
noto che dolorosa sora pazzesco però
ancora mai pericolosa no dài dài bene
mamma
e io no dai macché scasso è scarso ma è
poi ci credo non ci possa decidere se
non ci fosse direttore è mia ma come
faccio a essere precisi ma perché sa
perché mi hanno dato un joyce quando
sono nato perché ragazzi questo era
verbong su un vice di roberto birra
ponga postierla polvere su red hat trick
con il caro laurini si sveglia anche al
suo canale tra descrizione di sapere se
le più video del genere il workshop
molto figli tanto è bellissimo sarà
parente ma pro bella come sempre ci
diamo seguito dai ragazzi
[Musica]
no